i don't think he's coming
i think the baby's coming lil na's ex is
having a baby
okay by baby we mean he's about to
deliver his new album montero september
17th my new album ontario
a baby yeah montero is very much still
here i'm sucking in my stomach right now
uh-huh yeah the grammy winner is really
leaning into that whole pregnant having
a baby metaphor on tick-tock what can we
expect with this baby you're delivering
on the 17th this baby is going to be a
world changer on wednesday the 22 year
old posted several clips to his account
bump and all saying he was getting ready
for his baby shower but when it was time
for the party no one showed up
[Music]
lil nasdaq shared another clip walking
into the party blindfolded to reveal a
beautifully decorated space with no
guests
but there were lots of presents
seemingly from his famous friends megan
doja and miley megan the stallion doja
cat and miley cyrus to be exact then
there was a gift from elton john who
he's been collaborating with a lot
recently you look amazing oh you look
amazing thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you and jack harlow
who's on his track industry baby of
course little nasdaq's recently revealed
that they are all featured on his new
album what do you say to these people
i'm just like please please and thank
you hop on this song and it happens it's
been a big week for little nazix let me
give y'all something it's only a week
it's going to be a great week
it's going to be a week who attended his
first ever met gala on monday night
sporting not one not two but three gold
looks by versace on the red carpet
and a night before that the georgia
native had heads turning in this lilac
versace pantsuit with a matching train
at the mtv video music awards you are
serving up some fashion tonight
yeah stop it i was expecting a bump
tonight because you know the baby
i had to suck my belly in today the baby
is very much here and we'll be here in
five days shortly after that lil nazex
took home the vma for video of the year
for montero call me by your name the top
owner of the night
e.t was backstage with him after the big
win you are just feeling
next level right now i'm feeling like
i'm on cloud like
nine
179
million
google
i'm so thankful i'm so thankful
[Music]